de contre jour tu peux y aller en asie
compensera la rivière
dans l'histoire de tera
super ça j'aurais été plus heureux c'est
au maximum de serrer la pouvait-il son
plan à un jeu j'ai bien compris ajoute
le chercheur après après préfère pas
fini de finir là ok le typiquement
d'entente en se replaçant sur place sur
le corner un peu trop sur eux ils
trouveront crois que c'est bien un peu
calé à dubaï
au fait on a bossé bossé lonlas la mort
du zouk papoul
on a un coût des bas bon on refaire est
ce que tu es là c'est l'arbre était
assez large pour voir toute la région
apac faire de la vraie vie prend ton
envie pourtant le faire en tant que la
rivière
et bien pourtant lâché ovi mètres de
voirie fixa voilà voilà voilà c'est pas
eux qui fixent ce truc là bas c'est ça
qui paul et de fleurs incroyable à toi
mais tu es fou cette fleur c'est
magnifique ça voilà c'est exactement ça
qu'il faut faire
beh mans large vachement l'arbre plus
large possible
tu vois pas la rivière voilà c'est
superbe ça ah ouais ça qu'il faut faire
génial ça c'est super beau jeu sublime
bien dans quoi mais bien le voile avait
bien la fleur dans le coin à gauche je
veux c'est super voilà delargy de large
et élargira ses supers chevelure on
refait ou jeu bon jeu on va leur dire à
paul biya qui lui fait dire de sa place
exacte les wasps et c'est pourquoi c'est
sûr c'est pas du bon côté
non valeureuse de quoi battre ahmad tibi
a vu le petit pigeon vert qui est dans
le jeu blanc tu es vachement bon c'est
tip is over noirci vachement beau si
noir c'est sublime cela va durer
l'avocat va toujours dire que ça en face
à bayonne a pas eu vachement n'ai rien
fait
enfin pas politiquement salaires jacques
chirac en fera bon hockey et agir
nouveau salgado du coup parfait salgado
il finit bien as may have to show you
say me cause youtube est sorti si julien
contre le fatah au caire en battant la
tournée ok il mettait un peu peur
maintenant je ne suis plus là parce que
là sinon c'est bon on enrôle fait tout a
commencé là on a pu enfiler ok ok à
merde merde savais pas ça mais c'est pas
grave on va leur faire comme en effet
tout à l'heure c'est sa deuxième
dotation qui on leur prend le relais
en a pas trop de cours à tant attendue
n'est pas encore né pa pck on va le
faire alors je coupe on a tort ok plus
tard
ethiquement s'élargir pour bien aller
sur le lafleur et bien rester dessus
l'endroit très beaux restes et bien
dessus
bien continuer badia la rentrée la femme
à entrer
si on se concentre bien qu'en reste bien
le suc on la découvre bien que ce soit
beau très bien bien que voilà maintenant
tu n'en remonte un peu en descendent
lafleur bien en bas à droite on va en
tout cas pas du cadre
c'est très beau soleil est parfait
attention à l'arrivé que cette fin avec
l'éclosion je vais arrêter mourir les
olympiens je monte sur l'union de tous
bords de la rivière contre la rivière
monte la nature est bien cadré comme ça
voilà et il va finir en montant vers le
ciel mon vers le ciel vont de la rivière
m'a dit bon sens que je joue dans la
région je peins de référence qui monte
dans les inventaires des zooms
l'okavango des couples à korhogo c'est
exactement la rivière qui veulent en
désert là c'est vraiment le symbole du
truc du pontet tu montes landes et fait
signe au tricot tapote non non tu n'as
pas de tina pas du tout cela c'est
formidable j'ai mis l'hélicoptère de
façon on n'a pas le patin voilà c'est
pas beau ça
et voilà de bien ou pas de bon pas pour
vous ouais bon bon ok on tenant suisse
vise nommément racer peut le refaire
demain prévient ce soit celui d'hier
c'est que pour moi ça tourne pas voilà
ce propos comme ça paris 6 juil aps
avoir large au cas où tu vas à l'argent
pour y entrer jamais on prend dans le
mouvement suit avant
juste équitable ans l'a pas très
intéressant ce qu'il faut c'est la
matière qui est encore à mes côtés d'un
plan plus tard est le pas en passant on
arrive en arrivant plus on le sert à
l'arrivée sur place ou pâle copie
c'est pas dans la fleur dans la fleur
mais enfin c'est pas grave on attendra
un peu du mayon un peu des gâteaux et
vin à droite tu peux passer c'est beau
c'est super super la gauche battus à
tivat si la droite superbe et les
oiseaux qui par l'histoire et tu vas tu
en perds des données les oiseaux y est
vrai mais là tu es trop tout va c'est
super à ces super la matière là dedans
même assez incroyable
tapez de dorna avertissement c'est vous
bah voilà nous en tant qu il occupe at
ça fait pas trop mal mais vous fait
travailler plus dans même si puisque
j'ai obligé de compenser la chute je me
montrerai pacte en battant maintenant on
peut que pas du reste va au milieu ou
cibula regard hagard regard est à gauche
regarde à gauche maintenant on joue sur
des détails de dans la gorge de la
matière c'est super voilà voilà voilà
voilà voilà voilà fait pas de trucs
comme ça c'est que ce taux augmente
depuis une heure là voilà regarde pas
tous un peu là dedans c'est super beau
ça
voilà on va passer verticale au volant
à passer de reims et élargir un peu plus
tu as préféré l'avant toujours élargir
votre avis à quoi tu mens sur le banc de
sable qui est fatal
il ya un jour qui passe dedans c'est pas
super être ramasseur soleil je m'appelle
chabrier jamais être super patient
europe un tout petit peu quand un peu un
vraiment bon dans tous les sens le truc
des centres et campanie page 20 ici la
rivière peut être prêtre maroc c'est la
rivière est de voir le maroc au fond le
cargo voilà un joli ça voilà peut être
superbe pas la paille ific
très bien c'est bien ça il postule à
gauche ancien quotidien parce que c'est
pokerstars pour un coût de ce marbre du
bon là non du toit en toit un ami pour
vous mais c'est bon tu vois tu vois ce
que tu as fait ses pages sports via la
toiture de taper sur le détail se
demander où en est la rivière et pas
d'un seul coup tu découvres le truc on
était peut-être un peu où tu avais
trésorerie celle du donneur a tout à
fait raison et que tu vois un peu plus
bas alors si tu veux faire plaisir
on essaye de faire un truc qui partent
dans la nasse et pour ça on en fera sur
autre chose bichonne